here we are again just the girls scabs
reviewing some millionaires that have
covered their scabs potentially or just
they don't they're the kind of people
that don't get scabs no how many eyes
for some people you know now you know
your life is different now it's award
season and you know what we're just
doing it we're just doing it the Oscars
happened this weekend I watched zero of
it and that gives me the right to now
critique the fashions that were worn by
the people who participated in 100% of
it it's not for an Oscars fashion review
caveat as always I probably won't talk
about people that you might want me to
talk about I might talk about people
that you don't want me to talk about I
might pronounce names wrong you will
find a reason to get upset about
possibly anything in everything and
that's the joy of making content let's
just do it it was good nervous I get
nervous I get nervous I took a shower
this is my Oscars America Ferrera wow
this is cool like a Grecian wonder woman
oh so it looks like a very elegant like
bridesmaid at a wedding for one of the
Avengers and she's pregnant talking
about superpower creating life and just
shoving it out the not the pie hole the
the the other dessert hole jus it's
Kristen Wiig whoa this is very
fascinating
this looks like an inflamed vaginal
organ but like it knows what it's doing
this is what I think like a UTI looks
like but like it's super sexy just like
Sharon Stone starring in the Vagina
Monologues
cute Maya Rudolph ooh this is like if a
fashion competition show I had to like
elevate the comfy and I'm here for this
is how you would get me to go to one of
these award shows if you offered me the
opportunity to wear a glitter drape with
a pocket it's got a pop guy dick alright
this looks like a roll of fabric from
mood as an award show dress and that is
a mood cute Billy Porter oh my this
yeah at this point I can't imagine the
stress that Billy Porter must have to
consistently deliver to meet all of our
expectations of what we hope he delivers
and he did it again this is like um
phoenix rising from its own ashes cuz it
burned itself down and built itself back
up I can't stop staring at it this is
like the four horses of the Apocalypse
I want this plus three more leading me
through the apocalypse cute Sandra Oh
whoa okay I like this a lot I feel like
this is a poodle that's shaped in
Reverse I mean it's like the dog from
the neverending story on her arms all
the dust from under my couch was like
you know what we're not gonna be dust
today we're gonna dust ourselves off and
we're gonna put ourselves together and
we're gonna walk the carpet cuz we
deserve to elegant dander Jim Mindy
Kaling yellow looks beautiful on her
this looks very classic and timeless
it's like you're dislocated in your
right shoulder but in a super classy way
cute Sigourney Weaver I mean you look
amazing the green the emerald green is
beautiful first of all you don't age
second of all kudos to you for beating
science and again this kind of looks
comfortable maybe it's not but it kind
of looks comfortable Sigourney Weaver
and I finally have something in common
we both have knots in our shoulders I
haven't beat science that's the sign of
me aging with that joke Jim Greta Gerwig
ooh you look like an olive
this was very classic it's very like
Cinderella as a knowledge it got tight a
little belt on a seat belt for the olive
okay I gotta get away from this Olive
cute Florence put put put in it I should
know but I don't beautiful color this
aquamarine cake-topper from head to toe
this is like you start off your evening
really elegant and then all of a sudden
the mushrooms that you showed earlier
start to set in and
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa matrix all the
way down when is it gonna stop
oh and then there's aunt
whoa cute Timothy sha'lame oh can he not
I think he's been officially diagnosed
with he can't not this is like a suit
but it's a jacket and also kind of looks
like pajamas and also looks like he's
gonna take off in a fighter jet at some
point he looks like he just got woken up
from being cryogenically frozen and is
not happy about it at least he was
sleeping elegantly and comfortably yeah
Julia louis-dreyfus oh she always looks
so good and this is subtle and muted and
understated but impactful she looks like
the mother of the bride that paid a lot
for the wedding to see better fun at
this wedding and you know what everyone
does I'll eat the entire shrimp cocktail
bar I don't whatever you want cute
Margot Robbie uh I think she could just
wear anything and also nothing and look
outstandingly beautiful pirate wench at
the Pirates of the Caribbean ride stole
that necklace from the Titanic put it
for safekeeping on the outside of her
chest I might be obviously the best and
safest spot for it it's like sexy
tourniquets she's ready to give blood at
any moment cute
Olivia Colman ooh this is interesting
blue velvet all the way down how
luxurious her shoulders are little spies
and then you know people's also if you
kind of look at it and I swear I'm sober
it looks a little bit like with the two
buttons right here it looks like eyes
like a like a cartoon stingray just look
at look at it again look at it again and
tell me that doesn't look like a
friendly cartoon stingray right dude
saoirse ronan suave suave swarovski
swarovski Rogaine I don't I don't know
this is fascinating and also confusing
wow this looks like two different
dresses it's like your ribs are throwing
up but your legs put a tarp down for
good measure cute idina menzel this is
beautiful it looks very swishy like it
popped your hip a little too far for a
photo so they had to wrap you back in
and bring you back to centre cue brie
Larson uh
again always looks great everyone looks
great at this thing this was like a
magician's assistant like after the show
and she like put her jacket back on
and like wants to be low-key like she's
kind of putting her leg out there but
it's like else how many times have I put
my leg outfit it's look you see it I
have looks I you get it five yeah Regina
King Oh beautiful how did you sit ever
anywhere how did you get there were you
air lifted you probably just like power
walk there and it was better walking
than anyone else could possibly even
think of doing in their entire life kid
Julia butters oh is that her name this
is adorable
i I mean this is crazy and what children
should be wearing on these kind of
carpeted glamorous events this looks
like what I would design if I got put on
Project Runway and they were like really
push yourself and I'd be like I don't
know sleeves with sleeps but it's
playful also I heard that she had a
turkey sandwich in that purse I feel
like I need to consult her for how to
thrive cute laura dern oh god I love
Laura Dern so much and she always looks
beautiful this looks like a burlesque
dancer that just couldn't pick a tassel
so wore them all at once she can pull
everything off cute gal gadot oh wow
this is like Gilligan Oh saw what laura
dern was wearing since that hold my
Rosie
it's like Chicago on Broadway up top and
the Victorian Kleenex box on the bottom
cue Billy Eilish yep this is perfect
this is great it feels like a rebellious
teen took their step moms like expensive
Chanel power suit and was like you
you're not my mom and just burn it
cigarette into the front of it and then
went to the Oscars cute
Cynthia repo airboat areevo and this has
a lot of movement to it just makes me
feel like you're in a tit tornado but
it's second really expensive gale force
winds
cute Oh Johansson ooh this looks like
she took the idea of belly chains but
move them north chain mail but chain
female the jokes they're out about 80%
today guys huge oh I should have saved
the chainmail joke
janelle monae what how she always
delivers oh this is so cool this is what
I
wish my sleep paralysis monster look
like cute Charlize Theron oh and they're
on lies the problem is that this looks
great this looks wonderful
even like your shoulder is exhausted by
how glamorous this whole thing and you
are what else is there to say cute okay
that's it for this Oscars review again
sorry if I missed people you want me to
talk about my brain is operated not the
best percentage today so that's all you
get
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to this YouTube channel cuz
I make videos and isn't the
unreliability undeniable I know though
natalie portman this is cool also I
heard that she wrote all the names of
the female directors that weren't
nominated on her Cape very awesome this
looks like the princess from medieval
times but like in the middle of medieval
times she's like you none of you guys
actually need to save me I'm pretty I
got this while you were doing all that I
was creating a successful individualized
life for myself independent of whatever
this charade is in fact you're all
embarrassing yourselves I'll be over
here thriving and talking to that
butters girl about that turkey sandwich
yeah